[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
My name is Ilia Tulchinsky.
And I work with Google
Cloud Genomics team.
You are likely familiar
with standard tools
for processing genomics
data in BAM files,
like Picard and GATK.
Traditionally, they
take files as input.
But with more genomics
data coming to the cloud,
we have been working on teaching
these tools to read directly
from the cloud,
with Global Alliance
for Genomics and Health APIs.
Today I'm going to show
you how to build and run
Picard Tool against a data set
store with Google Genomics.
All the instructions
can be found
on our
googlegenomics.readthedocs.org
website.
Now these instructions
assume you
could be starting from scratch.
And so they walk you
from the very beginning,
through creating
a Google account--
if you don't have one-- to
signing up to genomics API--
if you haven't done so already--
and then creating a project,
and then finally setting up
credentials, authenticating
and getting access
to genomic data.
Now I have already gone through
these steps on my machine.
But please follow the
instructions on the page
if you need to do the set up.
Next step is
downloading and building
three packages we
need to make Picard
work with GA4GH APIs-- first of
all, Picard tools themselves.
Secondly, HGS GDK Genomics
File Access Library,
where we implemented support
for plug in GA4GH readers.
And then finally, GATK
Tools Java Library,
that contains the
bulk of the logic
for actually working on the API.
Again, I will skip these
steps, since I have already
done them on my machine.
At the end of the process, we
should have the following files
in our working folder.
Let's list.
First of all,
clientsecrets.json file,
that we got when we
authenticated, and then Picard
tools themselves, that we
have built with GA4GH support.
Now let's see if we can
run the basic ViewSam tool
and have a output
data from the cloud.
First of all, let's tell
the API which project
we will be working with.
We're using G Cloud
tool to tell the APIs
that we are going to be working
with project called Genomics
Test Data.
Now let's find the data
set that we are after.
We are going to use
G Cloud tool again,
this time to run Genomics API
command, to list the data sets
to which we have access,
and then find the data set
which is called Test Data.
So we've done that.
And we have the idea
of our data set.
Now we are going to
find the read group
sets that we want to access.
Read groups sets can
be roughly thought
as corresponding to BAM files.
So again, we are running
Genomics API command,
this time to list
read group sets,
that are under the dataset that
we found in a previous step.
Here is our read group set.
And we have its ID.
It's here.
And we are going to need
this for the command lines
that we are going to
specify for Picard.
Now I'm going to
paste a command line
and explain its components.
But first, let's switch
to the Picard folder.
So we have the standard
Picard invocation here.
We are using Picard JAR.
And we are issuing
the ViewSam command.
Now let's look at the input
parameter, which is here.
This url specifies the endpoint
for Google Genomics GA4GH API
implementation.
It's right here.
And then it uses the
idea of the read group
set that we want to use, that we
found a couple of steps before.
That's here.
And finally, we specify the
path to the secrets file
and that we need for
our authentication.
OK, let's run this.
OK, this worked.
We have run the
standard Picard tool.
But the input came directly from
the cloud, as opposed to file.
We can also run a faster
version of the API access
that uses GRPC technology.
It is more than 10 times faster.
Here is a command line.
And I'm going to
explain as well.
The command line
is almost the same.
But you need to add an
[? LAPN ?] JAR to the class
pass.
That's here.
And we have
instructions on which
file to use depending on whether
you have Java 7 or Java 8.
In this case, I'm using
the file for Java 7.
We also need to tell our
implementations that we
are going to be using GRPC.
And other than that, the
command line looks the same.
Again, we are using
a url as an input.
And we are specifying the
path to the secrets file.
Let's run this.
All right, so this
worked as well.
Now let's do something else.
Instead of specifying the full
read group set to process,
let's specify a genomic range.
Because we could
have a big data set,
and we want to
process part of it.
Here is how the command line
will look, [? like that. ?]
So you will notice, it's
pretty much the same.
And the input url
is very similar.
But not just that-- in addition
to specifying the read group
set ID here, we have also
specified the reference
that that we want to use
and the specific genomic
range that we want to process.
So let's run this.
So this worked.
And we only go the reads from
this genomics [INAUDIBLE].
Now this is not the only
tool that we have converted.
We can run another tool,
for example mark duplicates,
in a similar manner.
And we specify the
command line, as usual.
And the input is, again, the
url that points at our data
in the cloud.
Let's see this.
OK, so same Picard
invocation, except this time
mark duplicates
instead of ViewSam.
And the input is, again, a url.
Again, this worked.
So now let's review.
We ran several Picard
tools, reading data directly
from the cloud via GA4GH APIs.
We have worked on converting
several tools to support this.
And if you want to
help us convert more,
please read the
developer documentation
on the GitHub page for the
GATK tools Java project.
You can also use
GA4GH support we
have built into HGS
[? GTK ?] libraries
to easily enable your tool,
built on top of same libraries,
to read the data from the cloud.
Thank you very
much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]